hello my name is Johan veamos I'm the
founding partner of the Emerald asset
management we invest in Eastern Europe
for the last decade invested over
billion dollars we see the big future in
Eastern Europe and this conference in
cleantech in Eastern Europe because
Russians and East Europeans generally
waste four times times more energy than
West Europeans this you can make a lot
of money investing clean tech projects
in Russia we're just starting the
project with Republic of Tatarstan in
this regard investing 20 million euros
to Pakistan to try to benefit from best
practices around the world and hope to
find great technologies in this forum
and business partners along the way
thank you